all right next up we have a story about
some incredible young people stepping up
in their community cbs news reports that
there is an emt shortage in america
in rural areas 35
of ambulance services are volunteer and
69 of those are understaffed and in a
small town of sackett's harbor new york
a group of teens has taken the
initiative to get certified as first
responders in order to fill out their
local emt force
they're also students attending high
school full-time but they say putting in
the extra hours to help others in their
toughest times is worth it to them
i
i know the stuff i need to hear
this is the stuff i need to hear about i
need that belief system that good things
are taking place and good people exist
you have my deepest respect and
admiration thank you so much to those
teenagers yeah
and they think
you think about
i think about how they always say oh
these kids these days kids these days
that's right i know what the future is
going to bring i just when i read this
story it made me feel like if this is
the future
the next generation maybe because of
kids like this we're going to be okay i
agree and as a parent i could only dream
if my children did something like this
these parents i hope you're very proud
yeah you should be very proud we're
proud of you and you're good
next up we have an interesting study
from the uk metro reports a survey found
two-thirds of adults say that music and
stores and restaurants we've all heard
that well it can actually affect what
you buy in terms of genre pop music was
found to increase spending
more extravagant clothes or sneakers and
if um classical music is playing at a
restaurant 31 of people said they might
order a pricier entree i will tell you
this i was at home goods this past
weekend and they were playing like
classical music and then i realized it
was like a bruno mars bop and i was then
i was like oh i was in the mood and i
did buy three decorative throw pillows i
didn't need so i think there's something
to this story
i love that like um
classical music like induces a little
like 1980s gray coupon commercial where
you go a little fancier like all of a
sudden you're like i'll have the lamb or
you know whatever it is you order but um
i like that you shop and bop that kind
of is super cute and i totally get that
i will say this
i cannot eat
to a lot of styles of music music to me
is like really sexy and when i'm eating
i'm not thinking sexy thoughts i'm i'm
more like i want billy holiday or like
classical
but i can't like this is not
this is like
i'm much more of like
prone to the alley cats who are like
yeah
i'm eating
um
however cooking i feel like bring on the
music but when it comes time to eat i
can't sex and food don't go together for
me i am not george costanza who wants to
eat a turkey sandwich and do it if you
know what i mean
although that's the best episode ever
anyway
we'll be right back
[Music]
you